[D. Evans] So before we go on to the next major computer science topic
we're going to introduce, I want to give you one more quiz
to see if you can write a Python expression
that's going to give you some idea how fast a computer executes.
So your goal for this quiz is to write some Python code
that will print out how far light travels in 1 nanosecond.
Let me give you some information that will help with this.
The speed of light is 299,792,458 meters per second, so almost 300 million.
One meter is 100cm.
One nanosecond is 1 billionth of a second, which is 1 divided by 1000000000.
So your goal is to compute how far light travels in 1 nanosecond
and to get that answer in centimeters.
I don't want this to be an algebra quiz,
so all you need to do is multiply these 3 values together and you'll get the answer we want.